this game was played in 1851 between
adolf henderson considered to be one of
the greatest players of his time and
lionel ad albert bagration felix
kizeretzky which is a lot of names for
just one person to have humans call this
the immortal game because they think it
is so good that it will never be
forgotten but all games are immortal if
you have the pgn
e4 e5 and f4 white plays the king's
gambit a very popular opening during the
1800s
white pushes the f pawn to get black sea
pawn out of the center
however this opening is not good because
white's king is now severely weakened
play this against me and i will show you
no mercy
of course play any opening against me
and i will show you no
mercy
takes f4 and bishop to c4 developing the
bishop and attacking the weak f7 pawn
queen to h4 check
black takes advantage of the weakened
king and forces white to give up their
castling rights
this move is double-edged as the queen
will get attacked later
king to f1 and b5 i have learned
everything there is to know about chess
but i have yet to understand why humans
play like this
this move enters the brian counter
gambit
apparently this brian bloke believed
giving the pawn back for no reason was a
good idea and key zeratsuki liked the
sound of that
bishop takes b5 knight to f6 and knight
to f3 development with a gain of tempo
smart human
queen 2 h6 d3 and knight to h5 moving a
knight to the edge of the board to guard
a pawn that is already guarded
at least there is the threat of knight
to g3 check
white played knight to h4 but rook g1 is
better grand master john ms wrote that
this game has always been noted for its
brilliancy rather than its accuracy as a
computer this does not make sense to me
what can be more brilliance than perfect
accuracy
queen to g5 knight to f5 and c6 however
playing c6 now is just silly
the knight on f5 is much more dangerous
than the bishop on b5
g6 is superior
g4 knight to f6 rook to g1 and c takes
b5 humans are well known for their
desire for material gain
this dubious move is the beginning of
black's problems
a clearly better continuation was
h5 h4 queen to g6 g5 knight to g4 bishop
to a4 d5 queen to e1 d takes e4 and
after queen takes c4 check black has the
obvious king to d8
they played h4 and queen to g6 the queen
is the most powerful piece on the board
never mind safe squares how is it even
possible for her to have so few legal
moves
a centralized queen on an open board has
27 legal moves this queen has five
hahaha
h5 and queen to g5 seriously i hope she
is not claustrophobic lol
after queen to f3 black's queen is
nearly trapped
black is now forced to sacrifice the
knight or to retreat it
knight to g8
what a surprise
the human stubbornly holds on to the
extra material but now getting the king
to safety seems impossible
it's hard to play when all your pieces
are on their starting squares except for
your queen free advice from stockfish
after 14 moves i recommend you have more
than one developed piece
bishop takes f4 queen to f6 knight to c3
and bishop to c5 i hope this piece has
better luck in its future endeavors than
that knight did
it's another mistake by black
key zeratsuki thinks he is being cheeky
developing the bishop and threatening
the rook
i sometimes wish i could be this naive
knight to d5 i am surprised anderson saw
the best move
does he know his g1 rook and b2 pawn are
hanging or is he blundering his pieces
it is always hard to tell with humans
queen takes b2
black grabs a pawn threatens the rook
and saves the queen black however is
already lost
to d6
did i say lost i take it back
white manages to play one of the only
moves that ruins his position
anderson must have been enamored with
all of the mating ideas from this move
but they don't work as grand master zims
and hubner pointed out d4 bishop to e3
and rook to e1 would all have won easily
if anderson tried pulling a move like
this against me he'd be sorry
bishop takes g1
black seems to enjoy enemy rooks more
than he enjoys winning haha if you are
going to take a rook then take the one
on a1 and after king tu e2 and queen to
b2 white would have nothing to do except
maybe lose
if i can't find a forced mate then you
certainly can't
white play d5
is this what you humans call trolling
it seems like anderson gave up his
second rook just because he could in a
way i like his style
it's actually really hard for 19th
century so-called defense to avoid
checkmate here
queen takes a1 check and king to e2
white now threatens knight takes g7
check king to d8 and bishop to c7
checkmate or like some humans might say
it's gg start a new one
knight to a6 defending against the night
fork on c7
again with the rook obsession i wonder
if this stems from a childhood trauma
mate is now unavoidable
playing bishop to a6 in order to clear
c8 for the king would have extended the
game
but black is still lost so maybe lionel
was born just wanted to do something
else
some people even say he resigned instead
of playing anything i would play until
mate ha ha i just i never get checkmated
knight takes g7 check and king to d8
unfortunately for black even though c7
is guarded there is a way to mate on e7
instead
queen to f6 check i admit this is quite
a nice move i applaud this human for i
did not anticipate him finding it
a beautiful queen sacrifice for mate
keyserretsky must not have seen this
when he played knight to a6
19th century players were much better at
playing queen sacks than avoiding them
knight takes f6 and bishop to e7
checkmate a nice finish to this
otherwise deplorable game i am glad i
can format my disc so i do not have to
go through this again
however i must say
i do like the way anderson messes with
his weakling opponents i just wish i
could have done the same to him
don't forget to like and subscribe so
that you will be notified of my future
analyses of the best chess efforts of
humans